remember when your freezer actually had
stuff inside you wanted to eat great big
story remembers one of the most
versatile meals you could have it in the
morning you could have it in the evening
do you know where this is going this is
the story of pizza bagels and two guys
who met on a tennis court who brought
them both together this is Bob and this
is Stanley together they invented pizza
bagels bob was a caterer and his clients
only wanted pizza for their kids he
spoke to his pennis partners family
about his issue these people were saying
what we don't want to just pay for pizza
if we're getting a caterer bringing food
in so they came up with a plan so he and
I just sat down one day over the beers
and started thinking well you could put
people on bread English muffins on total
and then they hit it with the early 80
days out of the becoming a big thing
that's right
they put pizza on a bagel these people
started coming up to us and going Wow
leave it with Coco these are good with
this and that and whatever they were
serving Bagel Bites in hotels bars and
restaurants until they eventually became
a forever state ball at your local
grocery store originally called trunk
stuffers hot pockets were saving grace
when it came to needing a hot meal in
under five minutes with over fifty
different flavors from pretzel bread -
croissant pockets fruit hot pockets the
guys over there got pretty creative the
inventors are David and Paul meringue
two brothers from Iran who started a
us-based company in the eighties more
than just developing a food they
developed a technology to go with the
food they commissioned to the invention
of something called a susceptor a little
sleeve that you put the hot pocket in so
it didn't get soggy it got
krispy it was the first of its kind to
absorb electromagnetic energy and
convert it to heat the concentrate it
doesn't matter where you're from who you
are or what you've done your freezer
definitely had one of these tucked away
in the corner frostbitten to high heaven
but turns out there was a very
interesting story here we actually
talked to a food historian
her name is emmalin a lot of our food
habits surprisingly come from the
military and frozen concentrated orange
juice is no different
Richard Morris a businessman or the
background in science caught wind of the
challenge during World War two he
developed a vacuuming process to help
retain the flavor of the orange while
still dehydrating the fruit in the
process
the US military commissioned some five
hundred thousand cans but the war ended
before they could ship so Richard Morris
in turn took all of the money and the
investment and created what is now known
as Minute Maid and they have it your
favorite freezer foods and some of the
people behind them
[Music]